una apuesta que estuvo a punto de salir
mal cuando justin trudeau subió a la
tarima el lunes por la noche fue para
celebrar pero la victoria de su partido
liberal fue agridulce no obtuvieron la
mayoría absoluta que esperaban después
de que los votantes expresaron su enfado
por el hecho de que crudo hubiera
convocado unos comicios anticipados en
medio de una pandemia
[Aplausos]
los escucho cuando dicen que solo
quieren volver a las cosas que les
gustan no preocuparse por esta pandemia
o por unas elecciones que sólo quieren
saber que sus parlamentarios les
cubrirán la espalda durante esta crisis
y más allá acudes caises jones cuando
justin trudeau convocó las elecciones
con dos años de antelación apostó a que
los canadienses no elegirían un gobierno
conservador en medio de la crisis pero
la campaña se tornó rápidamente tensa y
a veces violenta y manifestantes anti
vacuna le lanzaron piedras a crudo sin
embargo la postura del candidato
conservador eri no tuvo contra las
vacunas terminó perjudicando le después
de que el virus empezara a hacer
estragos en alberta gobernada por los
conservadores tras la derrota o toole
arremetió contra crudo haber convocado
las elecciones y por haber prometido
convocar otra si los liberales no
obtenían la mayoría
y retó al primer ministro que anteponga
la unidad de este país y el bienestar de
su pueblo le dije que si cree que puede
amenazar con otras elecciones en 18
meses el partido conservador estará
preparado
al haberse esfumado el sueño de mantener
la mayoría en la cámara de los comunes
los liberales tendrán que volver a
apoyarse en la oposición con los nuevos
demócratas de tendencia izquierdista
para aprobar su plan de recuperación
fiscal tras la pandemia